since 2011 the stars of Impractical
Jokers have produced countless hours of
self humiliating comedy and a pretty
large number of running gags along the
way
loyal viewers probably caught most of
these weird references and Impractical
Jokers the movie but here are a few in
case you missed them viewers of
Impractical Jokers know that the show
focuses almost entirely on its four
charming stars who have known each other
since childhood Sal Vulcano Joe Gatto
James Murray and Brian Quinn but fans
truly in the know understand that they
have a fifth member and his name is
Larry Joe these FedEx has got to go out
you need Larry often screamed at but
never seen Larry is the go-to name for a
guy who always seems to be missing he's
to blame for the circumstances
surrounding a number of challenges and
even though nobody knows exactly what he
looks like or where to find him his
presence is known Larry makes his latest
non-appearance twice in the movie
[Music]
Larry's first non cameo is a reference
found in Q's license plates which start
out with lry the second time larry is
mentioned is after the group fakes their
way past security out of Paula Abdul
concert just as they sneak through the
doors cue announces on a walkie-talkie
that they've taken the arena the
response from the other end where's
Larry not coincidentally that was also
the name of their 2015 tour the entire
imaginary setup of Impractical Jokers
the movie takes place on Staten Island
in 1992 but look closely and you'll see
that Staten Island isn't all it seems we
can go a like a wacky adventure on
Staten Island yes director Chris Henchy
revealed in an interview with si Live
that it was too expensive to film
largely on Staten Island itself and
production had to resort to finding
streets in Cheaper locations that were
simply Staten Island ish fortunately the
scenes that were shot authentically
features some of the Joker's most iconic
locations he'll spot Monsignor Farrell
High School where the boys all went to
school together and later returned for a
lie-detector punishment focused on Murr
you'll also see Ladder Company 86 where
Q once served as a firefighter before
moving on to become a TV bigshot I heard
you were a great
no I'm an actor on television
fall back it's a word that basically
means nothing and everything but when
the boys are excitedly discussing the
nature of having exceptional testicular
fortitude the word ballbag is thrown
around a lot sure it's kind of funny on
its surface but it's also a distinct to
call back to one specific Impractical
Jokers episode where it makes its one
and only memorable appearance while
acting is wall climbing instructors
during the challenge appropriately
called repeat after me each one of the
Joker's must get their wall climbing
student to repeat a bizarre phrase or
word given to them by the other Joker's
Walmer tried and failed to have his
student repeat I'm going to die and Q
also failed to get his student to repeat
lump and proletariat Joe's succeeded in
getting his student to repeat ballbag
not once but twice you want Paul back
over there while you'd expect the
Joker's many recurring characters to
make appearances in their big-screen
debut
it was Murs quiet and strange Stanley
Merkle who made the most notable
appearance my name is Stanley Merkel I'm
checking out the weird character
originated as the winning costume in a
creep off competition filmed by the
Joker's for their 2016 Santiago sent us
- were not happy to just leave Stanley
in a video clip only seen by - or
attendees Murr brought the character
back for the TV show during a costume
change competition in which the Joker's
had to return to the same receptionist
multiple times without getting
recognized accomplished through the aid
of ridiculous costumes
Stanley returned once again in
Impractical Jokers the movie as a random
stranger who shows up to sit on Santa's
lap in the middle of a shopping mall
Santa of course is played by sound it
was enlightening
the Joker's are known to wear shirts
that promote their own personal
interests on the Impractical Jokers TV
show
Joe often wears a shirt that says adopt
don't shop and Sal seems to never take
off his wu-tang tee and while q can
often be seen wearing shirts that refer
to as various pop culture loves many of
his shirts also refer to his podcast
tell him Steve Dave which he runs with
Walt Flanagan and Brian Johnson of comic
book men paint and Impractical Jokers
the movie it's an especially deep cut
into Steve Dave lore a shirt that says
Prussian kissing devil which was
discussed in depth in the 300 13th
episode of the podcast allegedly the
Prussian kissing devil was a strange
sculptural head that Q attempted to buy
during his Thanksgiving
break in rural Pennsylvania with his
family strangeness ensues and the head
found its way into tes deal or and
eventually onto a t-shirt and while
we're on the subject of t-shirts Joe's
legendary I'm the beef shirt makes
another cameo appearance as well
Johnny's 1987 I was looking for the gift
shop the Joker's have attracted a pretty
impressive celebrity following and their
famous fan base appears on their TV show
often famous followers include Rosie
O'Donnell Danica McKellar and even Gary
Busey has appeared in several strange
skits and Impractical Jokers the movie
however things get weird while the voice
plays semi fictionalized versions of
themselves their real-life friends are
employed as some of the characters that
surround them easiest to spot is Casey
Jost the producer of the show and host
of Impractical Jokers inside jokes who
appears here as Sam a close companion of
Paul Abdul he's easy to spot not quite
as easy to spots as Kane Hodder a
hulking actor who plays Paula Abdul's
bodyguard later in the movie he's also
one of the actors who's played Jason in
the Friday the 13th series and it's
probably no coincidence it's well known
that cue is a huge fan of horror even
wearing a Friday the 13th hoodie during
some challenges when the Joker's parents
show up you know that it's about to get
really good so welcome to your father
have a seat your ass is about to get
punished while most of the Joker's
parents have appeared in various
capacities Joe Gauchos parents never
showed up for one simple reason they
both passed away fortunately it's a
subject that Joe can still joke about
during one waiting room challenge where
the Joker's all have to get each other
to laugh in order to achieve victory Joe
indicates that he's leaving to go
retrieve his parents he returns with a
pair of plastic skeletons and what's
perhaps the most touching hidden detail
in the entire 90 minutes Joe brought his
mother back one more time in a June 2019
Instagram post he revealed that he used
his late mother's picture on an employee
of the month plaque hidden in the movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]